howdy folks it's your boy joe derosa why
am i talking like this because i got a
big announcement to make i am shooting
my new one hour special
that's 60 minutes of new material for me
shooting it at the come and take it
festival in houston texas when real soon
may
19th that's a thursday and again on may
22nd that's a sunday we're doing one
show on thursday one show on sunday
that's it we're banging out this new
hour
i think it's going to be called i never
promised you a rose garden which is a
title that is making me laugh in my
day-to-day life
uh and as you can tell by the working
title it is an hour of uplifting
positive material folks i'm doing what i
do up there on the stage it is going to
be 60 straight minutes of pissing and
moaning bitching and complaining but i
promise you it's funny again one show at
the come and take confess on thursday
the 19th of may a second show on the
22nd which is a sunday in may doing both
very very very and i'm not just saying
this is a as a gag to sell tickets very
limited occupancies these are very small
intimate shows uh honestly i think
there's about 60 to 70 seats available
at for each show and tickets are already
selling so if you want to come out come
out get your ticket quick because
they're going fast it's going to be a
lot of fun and then
if you don't live in houston but you
live in texas maybe out in the austin
area on may 20th and 21st in between
these two shows i will be
doing shows at the creek and cave in
austin texas four shows two shows friday
the 20th two shows again on the 21st so
come check me out if you're in the
austin area and you can't make it over
to houston uh and then finally finally i
will also in june be at fort collins at
the comedy fort that's fort collins
colorado at the comedy fort
and then in july i will be at the punch
line in san francisco go to joe derosa
dot info
for information on all the dates i've
mentioned and to buy tickets for any of
these dates
again especially for that one hour
special taping in houston texas uh
that's that's a that's important so
anyway uh they're all important but you
know what i mean anyway i'll see you out
there folks april 23rd and 24th i will
be in tulsa and oklahoma city beacon
theater new york city first time may
14th there's going to be some surprise
guests there and that's all i could say
but you do not want to miss that and i'm
going out west cali i'm finally coming
to you i'm going to be in san diego on
may 21st and at the wilton theater in
los angeles for the first time ever on
may 22nd everything is available right
now at savolcanocomedy.com you little
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
bunnies welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buds
happy monday happy monday we're back
again with burt kreischer we're back in
the same clothes with the same face
marks exactly
you started a cultural phenomenon in the
last episode
guys since last week it is the alopecia
challenge has taken all of it i'm really
happy that we've killed oh do you like
the lottery thing you know the new york
state lottery is now and he looks at
he's like and then they just dub it i'd
be like guys this week for the alopecia
challenge we raised
35 dollars
to the english woman
uh
if anybody's [ __ ] up right now
right
i would like to add an artistic spin to
this a little tipsy i'm not even that
tipsy okay
but my favorite buzz is a morning buzz
okay yeah that's nice dude you like show
crow you like a beard buzz early in the
morning
by the way that's the sexiest part of
that song it is it is it is it is
remember when she was like the down home
like i'm the ch i work on a farm and
i'll bang you did she still think she
got like [ __ ]
she got cancer and he was like i'm not
dealing with that yeah no actually i'm
not even saying him he i know he was
like i kind of just went through that
with me and i'm
through that he's like have a bracelet
but i gotta go yeah yeah and so she
definitely
no but i'm saying that's what it was
like where he's like listen i've been
through this right you know like you got
to go your own route with this but you
can go your own right wait wait i have a
question
but shower crow i haven't heard now that
i've i know but as she's still active
yeah yeah
like she is yeah she's yeah yeah she's
still working
so cool yeah she was cool do you think
she looks like in person i don't know
when she back in the day i was like man
jesus i thought she was cool
yeah she was white tanks
jeans no shoes
smoking it like the cigarette of the
sunset that's when i liked her i didn't
like when she went if it makes you happy
and she's wearing like like
fancy dresses yeah i went to lilith like
straight hair and all that i like when
she was like wearing the [ __ ] she was
wearing like this
flannel and she was on the porch
you know what i mean yeah i like that
you see what one singer do you go i want
to drink in their height right in their
height of who they are the brand that
they are we go that would have been fun
now i'll start
fiona apple
um i just saw her did she come out a new
album recently i just saw her in the
news
she's so beautiful i
i think she's a wonderful artist and i
think she's an extremely attractive
woman yeah i don't think that ever would
have
really i think she would have been
reading you poems that she wrote i love
it and saying i want to talk about your
soul she would have changed who i was
and i would have started writing poems
who would be your height a lot of sports
set just anger oh we're talking about
yeah
for anybody you can date a dude if you
want yeah oh he's about dating okay
like i want i don't even know who you
who want to be around for that hang on
no no no i want to have something oh
okay
though i think i think atlantis would
have been a lot of fun to like
she just knows you would go out and
drink with you like yeah i don't know it
should be cool oversized sweaters
so we're going is that the arrow going
no no you can do any error you can do
joni mitchell okay
you can do uh etta james
okay okay well now you're going back
now i got to think about it but i i feel
like i want to say because how do you
not do oh wait a minute
wait a minute i just opened up a can of
worms
i'm gonna go
height
maybe
maybe
janet jackson
yeah yeah
uh
yeah i was going to go madonna
immediately hey day madonna actually
thrown around actually that's that's my
pick yeah
i was just
remember the sex book i'm going late 80s
madonna you're late 80s i'm going get
into my groove yeah
come on come on you can do that oh my
god
are you kidding me come on come on oh
she would have dive barred all over new
york with you madonna might be the pick
i thought it was too obvious then i was
like zigzag and i was like oh you know
paul abdul in the heyday too but i know
polos i don't mean no disrespect
but i think i i i respect paul yeah i
don't think she would have party chick
though maybe i'm wrong oh she was not
wrong were you a courtney love
no no way
no really yeah one day how was it
it was like you'd expect i feel like now
would be fun but i feel like back in the
day it would be like you don't [ __ ]
love me oh yeah
oh
oh
oh
susanna hoffs
who suzanna hoffs
wait that's not the bengals melinda
carlisle oh hold on i'm going bjork
no way you're nuts
ripping girl's hairs out at the airport
throwing out you're
[Music]
where is she
uh she's in a new movie coming up is she
really
serious
as you sip your she was [ __ ]
bjork york was like no you're nuts with
bjork oh that's a nightmare dude that's
that's a that's that's tonight that'd be
like dating
okay game changer dolly parton oh
yeah very good in her height very good
reynolds best little horror house in
texas yeah that's a very good absolutely
but i'm telling you madonna is the one
but donna it was
back in the day madonna would have been
like where's your shot
yeah yeah like she's come on dude that's
the one
but you know what the thing about
madonna is i think she'd be focused on
her dolly parton would be focused on you
like you you could have a great time oh
sugar
yes i agree with that but i also feel
that
dolly was gorgeous but like i feel like
and cool cool
good person i met her but i feel like
she wouldn't be a party i feel like
dolly would have been like god bless you
sugar you're going to drink like that i
mean all right
stick around
one guy that beat me in the holler
yeah you know what i mean
yeah
whereas whereas you know what they used
to party lily tomlin
lily tomlin used to party all right
let's go let's talk nine to five
fairy kill nine to five cast
lily tomlin
uh
yeah oh jane fonda yeah all right
i'm gonna go [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] jane
fonda i'm gonna kill lily tomlin and i'm
gonna marry dolly parton i gotta tell
you i might i'm gonna marry lily
i'm gonna marry dolly i'm gonna [ __ ]
lily i'm gonna kill fonda i feel like
fine that might be a buzz kill once in a
while once in a while
[Laughter]
whoa who's saying uh
yeah what about shania twain
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
what about that song look at me the best
thing about the best thing about being a
woman it's a prerogative to have a
little fun
that's horrible
sounds horrible i just think there need
to be more songs with though
dude you know what i bet you know what i
bet was a party back in the day
cindy lauper uh we tried to get on the
show got oh she's got a she's got a uh
uh yeah psoriasis
psoriasis yeah you mean bursitis you
mean is that what yes i don't know i
expect you to say you got very
that's the information like it's like
you name sydney lobby and the first
thing that goes through all this you
know she has psoriasis
she's in those commercials oh she's
really
i got psoriasis yeah i got it in my arms
it's all over
and i think that's the commercial we're
just talking i bet she was a party back
there today
look at this we got we got double thank
you chris
by the way we're here at joey rose's 174
ravington street
yes we've been eating sandwiches not let
down did not let it down i've been
thinking about this place
for a long time that's different than
this and we got our new uh side dish
fried dough here this is a cinnamon
sugar and that's a powdered uh powdered
sugar i have yet to have a zip
oh and it's what
is it hot
it's hot as [ __ ]
how hot is it
oh wow i smell that oh my god yeah
that's really good from here yeah it
smells like cinnamon toast crunch
yeah how was it all right it was awesome
did you try the powdered one
this looks like it could be an issue
with with with a mess
i'm wearing a black shirt but it's a but
it's a funnel cake vibe which i love i
like that there's a small one actually
maybe i'll pop the small one pop the
small
right
not bad
it's funnel cake
yeah
when i was on burger conqueror i
couldn't say another phone case
how often does it come across okay
[Music]
yeah seriously how often do you
personally every day i'm about to
conquer how's that
is that always what you did it was a
theme park every day there was a [ __ ]
theme park
every day they're like should we get a
thunder
best fun cake in the country i'll tell
you right now knott's berry farm best
funnel cake in the country really hulk
berry farm has the best food
i can't believe i went against funnel
cake and retro oh wait i think i did the
boston uh cream or something right
yeah [ __ ] that's a tough one funnel
cakes are [ __ ] legit yeah that's a
tough one but fried dough never
uh doesn't deliver anything fr fry you
know frying things
in general
what's been cool when you came up with
that and they're like hey man i've i got
something was cute it was cotton candy
versus funnel cake oh okay i wasn't
there for that yeah if you did you guys
know if you boil oil and put food in it
it's pretty good isn't that amazing the
uh by the way today's battle
because
bert bert the christian the conqueror
is here yeah is here uh we wanted to at
least do one alcohol uh battle in this
double up so we're doing bloody marys
versus mimosas
uh bert and i are team bloody mary which
is why we have them sal is going to
mimosa cheers cheers buddy oh we could
all choose i'm not going to go oh i'm
sorry i didn't mean to leave you out i'm
sorry i didn't mean to leave you oh my
god that is so
that is so fulfilling immediately it
makes you feel like you're being healthy
like you're taking care of nutrients and
vitamins that you didn't know you needed
now they're in your system you're not
being gluttonous you're being a little
bit of richard simmons a little bit of a
health nut you juiced it does taste like
fresh squeezed orange juice here it's
not a big difference all the only thing
that's happening with you guys is you're
eating literal tomato sauce through a
straw
i love that you think that's fresh
squeezed orange juice that's adorable in
my head it was yeah yeah you know just
for the battle it is yeah no i mean this
is
this is i i do agree with bert like when
you when i said this
i'm almost like i i don't need to eat
for the rest of the day i feel like i'm
eating a salty milkshake in a way what's
beautiful
the more you talk about it the more
disgusting it is what's beautiful about
the bloody mary is the amount of
variants
they can
razzle dazzle it with you know like you
put in a little bit of celery some olive
blue cheese olives a little bit of bacon
and then all of a sudden it's a
presentation yeah it's more than a drink
it's it literally is an event it's i
remember the first time i saw fajitas
and i thought now that's how you eat
dinner i was 10 years old they brought
them out we were benigns my dad said you
[ __ ] with sizzling yeah oh and i went
why isn't everything in life like that
yeah
why don't they go
swinging in like that you know
i remember that too i remember seeing
fajitas for the first time in a mexican
restaurant or hearing them rather
from across the room and i was like oh
my god like that feels like you're out
to dinner
it is more sizzle than it is like it's
sizzling it comes over
split every time when they go do you
want steak or shrimp or chicken i go i
want steak and shrimp down in the middle
it always is more promising than what it
turns out to be
you're nuts no you hear it coming food
come if you see food coming to the table
it's always a great thing and the fajita
is like an alarm that's coming it's
great and it's fun and they drop it down
and don't touch the thing it's hot okay
thank you for watching i touched it
anyway
and you make the whole thing it's fun to
make it then when you bite it like this
is good but
it's like the same dish as every other
mexican american
if you're on a health kick you get to
control your portions you get to decide
how much cheese goes in how much hot
sauce how much sour cream oh the sour
cream oh my god you know what i like to
do oh my god i just want a dish i
learned for the first time in my life
for real organic i just went
like i was like i was like tasting it as
you were saying it we have a place
called salsa version
i never no no i never legitimately in
real life went
like like oh my god 47 years you never
did that no i never did that you gotta
talk to believe you got a problem with
that
you it's hard to believe that i never
once mind eating
in the inside in air sounds like a
crocker [ __ ] but uh
no no i'm
you what place you have in l.a salsa and
beer
and they have like five different hot
sauces salsas you can use
and they bring out the shrimp and steak
fajitas and i always say uh give me a
full order of steak and a full order of
shrimp because i never get enough
and i take their their orange salsa and
i drizzle it all over the feeders in the
thing then their green one drizzle it
and then i let it sit there and cook in
those juices a little bit longer and
then i just go just meat and no cheese
no nothing
i don't think i've ever walked out of
that
no i'm doing it i'm swallowing yeah see
it's like first time in your life i've
never done this before
why don't you challenge him the way he
challenged me i just did go ahead no no
go it's hard to believe like you said to
me because it's not his first time he's
without him doubt him with normal human
beings we do it biologically yeah what
do you get at a mexican restaurant then
just quesadillas no i got the vegetables
i'm just saying that ultimately the
fajitas like they aren't the best thing
in the world okay nobody said they were
the best thing in the world we said it's
a great thing have you ever had menudo
the band no have you ever had menudo the
soup it menudo yeah is the best hangover
food you could ever have
it's i'll tell you right now i'll tell
you right now if there's a place out
there that could make me a minuto
uh bloody mary got to be in l.a dude
noodle consistency of all the places i
want i want i want
five puerto ricans children oh and i
want it to be like part soup
it's [ __ ] genius
people see a problem with this thing
you call this a drink and then you just
went ahead to say there's bacon celery
well hold on olives it's a drink let's
back first of all
we gotta start we need to throw food
scraps in it
above the ice we gotta start let's start
the battle i wanna try
let's start the battle because we're
we're wasting like too many good points
right
sure sure no seriously right sure are
ready yeah
oh here we go you already have one ready
to go oh yeah all right
you want to go first
uh why don't you go first for once sure
all right right yeah
it's time to get salty and salty it's
sounding salty i believe five percent of
the things you say come out of your
mouth five percent of things what do you
mean you don't you you're not a truth
teller
you think i lie i talk [ __ ] all the time
i think you get caught up in your own
[ __ ] and you say stuff like
i never did that in my life which is a
crock of [ __ ] and everybody knows it
wait are you talking to me or him
okay
all right you don't like it all right
you know this is your game
i needed to come up with something it's
our game [ __ ]
you brought you made the game up okay
ready yeah sometimes you'll just say
[ __ ] i mean you do it on this podcast
all the time sorry about i know i get it
all right v
all right ready look at it look at the
contest you're such a you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're you're you're you're you're so
joking she understands the difference
you're so arrogant and what you do okay
you ready
ready yeah it's time to get salty it's
time to get something
you've looked better
you got to hear mine and make sure you
did the worst one you've looked better i
don't know what to tell you you look
much better i could not breathe
actually i got to be honest
i was looking at both of those he's got
bert chao sal bert who's who over here
oh
you guys do actually kind of a similar
thing going on right now you um yeah
that one doesn't really hit slice hard
with me because i feel the same way
all right
here we go
all right
the duties and the simplicity
the less words you could deliver it in
it's more syllables you look better
yeah folks spring is here i think it's
here it's here it's got to be here right
we're deep into april at this point
anyway
uh when i think of spring i think of a
lot of things a lot of lovely things
come to mind and one of the first and
foremost of those things is soft
beautiful green grass
maybe you like to lay in the grass maybe
you like to walk barefoot in the grass
maybe you like to do something on the
lawn from a famous poem or play one of
those plays or whatever
famous things with something something
on the lawn i believe as a title of
something anyway people it doesn't
matter i want to talk to you about
sunday
sunday is a company that's going to help
you grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty
chemicals okay their custom plans
include fertilizer and everything you
need to easily care for your lawn
and they've got ingredients like seaweed
and iron and molasses so you can feel
good about your kids and your pets being
out there you know what i mean you don't
want your loved ones and your loved
animals running around on chemical
ridden grass that's terrible
all you got to do is take a sunday ready
to use pouch you attach it to a garden
hose and you spray that's it takes less
than 15 minutes
sundays also offering our listeners 20
off full season plans start at just 129
and you can get 20 off of that already
great price at checkout when you go to
getsunday.com
taste buds go ahead and visit that
website it's get sunday dot com taste
buds that's 20 off your already
awesomely priced custom plan at
getsunday.com
folks it's spring as we've established
in the previous ad
spring means what it's time to bring
that body out that you've been keeping
in storage all winter
sometimes that can be a tough thing it's
easy to slack in the winter it's easy to
you know fall off of the diets and and
the eating regimens and all that sort of
thing and indulge during the holiday
seasons in the richer
foods and the beverages and all of these
things and look i'm not talking about
you got to have a stone hard cut body
but sometimes you just feel better about
yourself if you're doing the right thing
for yourself one of the right things you
can do for yourself is exercise and yes
you know where i'm going with this it's
peloton that's what we're talking about
peloton is here to keep you motivated
how by keeping your routine not routine
by changing things up and adding adding
variation to your exercise regimen
regiment i know regimen sounds like a
bad word but peloton is here to make
that word not bad not scary anymore it's
here to give you a personal experience
uh when it comes to your exercise and
here it's here to let you personalize
your exercise i use the peloton app okay
and both are great these people make a
great product and a great
service
they offer great things i like it i like
getting onto a bike and looking at
something that makes me
feel charged up to keep going i'm not
staring at a wall i'm also honestly not
staring at a tv show i don't find that
that helps while you're exercising i
find that to be very distracting and it
keeps you off of what you need to be
doing uh but
you put you put a screen in front of me
with an instructor you put a screen in
front of me with with uh
a stoney cobbly road in italy
hey folks i'm in i'm doing it peloton is
here to help you keep things interesting
there are also peloton's also got a ton
of cool new additions this year they've
got boxing how cool is that discover a
fast and furious and fun way to work out
with your instructor who's in your
corner get some boxing going
there's new artists music selections uh
there's more daily workout variety if if
there wasn't enough already there's even
more now i i just think this is cool
that you you can with the artist series
pick pop and rock or edm whatever it is
or or search over a hundred artists
series to choose through and skim
through find what you like find what is
going to make you want to hit your mark
on a daily basis to go
i feel good i did something today uh
this is the thing for you take it from
me i'm not an exerciser kind of guy i
like stuff like this it gets you up it
gets you moving and it keeps you
interested anyway go visit peloton uh
i'm sorry
anyway go visit onepeleton.com to learn
more that's o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
all right we're doing it we're doing
god damn we're doing blind
versus mimosas the brunch drink right
yeah these are the brunch drink these
are the hangover drink this is nurse
your drink nursery hangover excuse me
with a drink here we are uh i want to
start by saying
even though i'm not a fan of it
i do agree i'm a fan of the drink the
bloody mary even though i'm not a fan
with the elaborate presentation because
like sometimes it goes too far
i do appreciate the showmanship of it of
course it's great when the guest yawns
uh admitted into it we just ate two
heroes and zeppelin i'm hurt right now
right
right what are they what are they
brussels sprouts i mean it's a
doubleheader
i'm so tired
i'm so tired
i really do want to go to bed i was like
thinking about it
all right
even though i'm not a fan of the
accoutrement with the bloody mary yeah i
do appreciate the showmanship of it and
i do think that it puts it ahead of the
game
against the mimosa because the mimosa is
the mimosa that's it it's it's usually a
champagne flute with arch houston
champion that's it that's it that's it
it's two simple ingredients that combine
to say make something better than some
of their parts
first of all orange juice is my favorite
drink of all time it's magical i love
orange juice it's your favorite drink of
all time orange always has been orange i
love watermelon juice yeah orange juice
swear to god i don't have to i will not
back down from that i said in my whole
life but no one's just gonna point out
that watermelon juice is the worst juice
you've ever had in your entire life i
was wondering like yeah watermelon juice
like you drink it like oh it's so bad it
seems like it would be great and then
you drink it
that's too much that's too much it's
like it's like having sex with a porn
star not that i've done that but i
imagine that you'd be like oh i already
came so fast i don't even need anymore
yeah well you know why i don't get that
because you don't get the support
i don't get the the analogy
it's like if you wanna have a sex with a
porn star you wanted to last like orange
juice yeah but you know you're gonna
come fast i mean like it's already over
i didn't get to do all the things i
wanted to show you drinking watermelon
have you ever had watermelon juice i
have i'll tell you why i think it sucks
why
because you think and i say this about
watermelon all the time i hate
watermelon i hate it i love watermelon i
hate watermelon's delicious but i love
watermelon flavored things gum exactly
because watermelon flavor jolly rancher
is very different from watermelon and
when i see watermelon juice i think it's
going to taste like watermelon flavored
things and it doesn't it tastes like a
soft
sh it's bright pink you're like this is
going to be so tight you're talking
about like a processed open a bottle
that you bought at a store or the juice
that comes from the melon yeah yeah i'm
talking about the watermelon juice you
bite the supermarket you know how you
see that
like a watermelon
like a watermelon drink
well i mean you could get a watermelon
flavored drink no watermelon flavor
watermelon juice you can only get at a
place that squeezes watermelon juice
usually yeah you know so far
when you've ordered it just as the juice
yeah oh yeah i've had i've had it i've
had just juice
it's gonna taste like strawberry
lemonade and then you sip it and you're
like this literally just tastes like
sugar water that's it
it's funny i think what they do when
they taste when they
when you get watermelon flavored candies
is they just get the smell of it because
when you think of watermelon flavored
gum it's oh now i want watermelon um so
good so good they were so tart and good
i could only take it in in the small
increments watermelon it's too much for
me we'll see talking about small
increments the best mimosas you can have
is when it's a splash of orange juice
and gotta be honest with you at a
certain point you're just gonna get the
shakes from sugar
this is a healthy beverage it is vodka
the cleanest alcohol you can put in your
body filled in with what literally
health nuts drink all the time let's
let's take away all the accoutrement
okay let's just talk about the two
ingredients
tomato sauce
and vodka juice is different than tomato
sauce
those aren't the only two ingredients
it's it's it's an iota away from
tomatoes that's not fair those aren't
the those aren't the two ingredients
because there's a reason they sell
bloody mary mix in a liquor store
because if it was if it was just tomato
juice they wouldn't sell that sure
seasoned hot sauce
i don't want to sip liquid that feels
like i'm eating dinner
in the morning i just don't want to do
it it's it's a thick
hearty i feel like i'm drinking gravy
really yeah i do not like it
for you you look like you drink gravy so
i don't understand where you're coming
from with this
you look like a man that drinks gravy
what are you talking about what are you
talking about dee what are you moaning
about over there he's you're taking a
juicy it's too mean you know what this
[ __ ] [ __ ] said to me on this show
what what
just watch him spiral he's smiling out
of control spiral chris rock best
performance
champagne champagne is an elegant
it's celebratory it's occasional you
don't overdo it oh this is because this
is cultural in a white house or a juice
isn't occasional but in like a latino
house like yours it's like uh
[Music]
orange juice in a champagne it is a big
day in our house mama bought an orange
juice what is that i don't know i'm just
doing it i like a spanish girl
[Music]
we toast with the orange juice
these oranges should sprout seeds in her
uterus
hey sal
come and cut the oranges
hey mama's got orange juice
now you're
no that's my big fat greek wedding what
is that what buys puerto rico
what is joey for tonight
it's refreshing it's actually refreshing
it's it's it's light it is refreshing it
is it's you can't overdo it but it's
like it gives you a little pick-me-up
it's it's it's bubbly it's it's it's
vibrant this is just
it it's tomato sauce no it is and it's
it's heavy and it's weird i don't in my
head my brain cannot reconcile having
something that i have like with pasta
with my vodka this is not a fair
argument you're making right now what
are you talking about as you slur your
dumb words
you dummy
yeah all right listen
just because my eyes are closed don't
doesn't mean i'm drunk
that should be a t-shirt that should be
a t-shirt
just because my eyes are closed doesn't
mean i'm good
folks
taste buddies
look he's slumping out of me we
we have drank so much today already
[Laughter]
i i anyway no listen to me
it's it's it's not a fair argument
you're making it would be you like what
do you like better uh let me ask you a
question what do you like what do you
like better orange juice or tomato juice
is this general rule as a general
refreshing drink what do you like better
okay so that's
that's literally there's two main
ingredients you just chose mine
but that doesn't matter that's how they
sell scientology there you go do you
believe in aliens listen i want to show
you some literature about orange juice
that doesn't matter
you know what you're a guy that only
sees two genders you know you see
everything too simply i like this i love
i love this
that is not true because i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm looking at right now
[Music]
it is the day of my daughter's casino
orange is for everybody
what this is that's not what happens in
hispanic households
is not a hispanic by the way i want to
make sure i want to make sure everybody
knows we're not making fun of hispanic
people
i'm here
specifically and if you guys want to do
irish german people
swing away
no but what i'm saying is is yes as as a
drink when i'm thirsty
whatever it is yes orange juice to me is
much more refreshing obviously than
tomato juice but that doesn't matter
when it comes to an alcohol beverage i
don't like tardy fruity flavored drinks
i don't like it no i like a salty i like
a bread i like it yeah i get a martini i
get it dirty my main go-to drink is
whiskey on the rocks i don't like a
sweet whiskey same but yeah i still like
that better than that
this feels like you took a plate you
took the plate at brunch
over the over the thing and just scraped
your plate into the cup threw some ice
in there if you were gonna if you're
gonna say that
define them as women the women you date
what is this girl versus what is this
girl if i'm gonna date one this is the
girl who's a little bubbly high energy
we should go to yoga i swear to god
these are the things i like we need to
do gratitude every morning but this is
the girl that makes you think at night
because you're like where you're like
you're like [ __ ] man i never thought
about the matrix that way yeah
i gotta be honest i don't understand
this analogy
i'm just gonna be honest
the parallels you're drawing i hear it
going over my head oh i'm not getting
the connection
why does tomato juice make you think
this is a hand job okay if like it's fun
for a little bit but then if you keep
doing it it starts hurting you're like
ow ow stop stop stop this is a vagina
you could do this all night long you
think you could drink tomato sauce all
night long i have oh no you have
you drink bloody mary's as a drink of
choice throughout the night
what is your what is your what are you
doing vomiting what's your heartburn
when you're going to sleep what are you
[ __ ] out right maybe this is a this
is a nationwide
contest bloody i don't even like your
name blood
this is
disgusting
it's bad enough that it's tomato sauce
now they're going to
who's got the who's got the greatest
bloody mary in the country the bloody
mary championship they give awards
that's because they know about the
mimosa it's a basic [ __ ] be honest it's
a basic [ __ ] the the mimosa sometimes
basic in pop culture is in pop culture
because it's popular for a reason it
appeals broadly
basically you call it basic i call it
broad appeal
a bloody mary it's the most disgusting
sound of drink i've ever had about a
mimosa i don't know what
bruce which sounds amazing it sounds
like it's tasty bruce
i'm trying to google bloody mary i think
what bert i think what bert was trying
to say earlier
was
the mimosa looks great
but then when you get to know it there's
not a lot of substance that's what i was
meant to say it's sort of it's sort of
trite and and annoying and and you go oh
god and they seemed cool but they're
actually annoying the bloody mary comes
in under the radar and you look over and
you go holy [ __ ] who's this i i didn't
notice her at first i wouldn't marry her
yeah and she's like a soldier
i've got a lot under my got a lot under
these clothes going
for this this bloody mary right here is
the nerd in high school but then when
you dress her up for prom all the all
the cool kids
she's all that she's home
the bloody mary for me is a woman that
uses a throat thing to talk because she
smoked her whole life and she comes with
a lot of baggage and now we're going to
do this
salty it's thick it's it's just like
if this is the away part this is like
hey doll what do you want from me doll
what are you doing it's just too much
when you need all the help you need to
throw in celery bacon you don't need to
do it
do you see anything thrown in here and
it's delicious it's delicious it's it's
it's it's it's a spicy tomato we drink i
love it
by the way also do you drink tomato
juice on the on the reg
no i don't
i wouldn't mind kale in that i wouldn't
mind like a real breakfast tomato juice
at all do you drink tomato juice at all
it's like drinking ketchup thank you
excellent
anything spicy tastes like ketchup you
like my father-in-law you're like oh is
this salsa no it's ketchup guys
about drinking ketchup about drinking
you're not drinking ketchup and you
goddamn no you're not so stop
but i'm going to tell you this right now
it doesn't matter i don't we're not
talking about drinking regular drinks
versus drinking we're talking about
drinking alcohol drinks
i don't want us a savory
there's a reason why the hangover every
time
almost exclusively is met with the
bloody mary because it dude i've been at
the bar late forget the hangover i've
been at the bar late at night where i'm
like i've had too much drink and i'm
like i'm like woozy but i don't want out
of the hour day for him right and then
i'll have a bloody mary and i'll be like
oh it's settled me right up like i'm
settled
a mimosa will never do that even when
you're trying to hair the dog the next
morning you have a mimosa a lot of time
you go oh my god it like showered my
shoulder you know what i'm not doing so
maybe we're just two different ships
passing at night but i'm not worrying
about what cup of alcohol i need to help
me with all the other cups of alcohol i
had i have that with some french toast i
have a glass of it it's light it's
fruity i have it maybe on a on a boat
and then that's the end of it i'm not
like i need a concoction to help me be
good again because i [ __ ] don't know
how to live my life and i can't control
myself and i'm gonna dump sauce in there
so it feels like i have some sustenance
it's just one point it's just one point
i'll give you another point when you
walk around you see mimosa in one
context in one context only it's brunch
bottomless mimosas that's it now you see
that with bloody mary's but you see
bloody mary's in many other contexts at
bars all day bloody mary's we have the
best bloody mary in town dude where are
you you're in houston you got to go here
for the bloody marys oh my god people
call you you know what dude i want to
place on a good bloody mary like every
single time
every single time you say bloody mary
not only is it disgusting but i think
that someone's going to come out and
kill us you just said it five times in a
row and i'm looking over my shoulder
bloody mary bloody mary bloody mary
that's disgusting why is the drink
called bloody anything so
it looks like blood let's get that let's
go it was originally called [ __ ]
so um they're both from made in the
1920s
and both in paris and um
actually about the mimosa it has about
like 144 calories per serving and the
bloody mary has 200 to 400 calories but
it's healthier
so if you're trying to lose weight do we
know why it's called bloody mary i guess
someone just named it like i guess it's
probably just uh it's just like it was
just like embarrassing
mimosa is probably another language for
orange or something like that for upsell
this champagne
yeah and by the way half your mimosas
champagne my ass
champagne my ass you're getting brute
whatever the [ __ ] uh what's that stuff
called uh what's the sparkling wine that
they pass off of champagne
and then they have all the offshoots of
brother of of mimosas they have
bellini's i like it the first time
where was the first time you ever had a
mimosa i remember mine
i don't remember oh i was in
jacksonville florida it was after our
formal white tea rose and they said they
have bottomless mimosas
what a formal like a date formal okay so
we all brought a date we all stayed in
jacksonville and then we were driving
home and we stopped and got brunch and
they said bottomless mimosas and i drank
until i was physically [ __ ] ill of
course you did because it's delicious
well yeah and i didn't understand i was
like bottomless and i just thought i was
like i gotta get my money in before they
notice not realizing we just won't cut
you off sure and i just [ __ ] and then i
remember being in the car like this we
had to drive from jacksonville to
tallahassee i was like oh i'm gonna
throw up i should not have eaten like
that people this podcast is sponsored by
better help you've heard us talk about
better health before and i'm going to
talk about them again why because it's a
great product people don't always
realize that physical symptoms like
headaches teeth grinding even digestive
issues can be indicators of stress
let's not forget about doom scrolling
we've all been there on your little
phone or whatever uh you're sleeping too
little you're sleeping too what much
you're under eating you're overeating
these are all things that be that can be
caused by stress and anxiety
uh i suffer from it i have talked about
that not just in these ads but on this
podcast and on many other podcasts i i i
think anybody doing a service that gives
a convenient way to help alleviate this
sort of thing
is doing god's work i think it's amazing
and better help is a product that i have
used i can tell you it's great and it
works okay
try it out just try it out better help
is customized online therapy they're
offering video uh they're offering phone
therapy even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
either that's great a lot of therapists
will only see you in their office and if
not you have to do a face zoom with them
and even that's hard to come by a
therapist that'll just talk to you on
the phone
good luck it's tough to find take it
from a guy who's been in therapy for
over half of his life
so
it's this is affordable
more affordable than in person therapy
can get incredibly expensive trust me it
can i know this is an affordable way to
get the help you need give it a try and
see if online therapy can help alleviate
or lower your stress this pro again this
podcast is sponsored by better help and
taste buds listeners are going to get 10
off your first month at
betterhelp.com taste buds that's b e t t
e r h e l p
dot com
taste buds help yourself
folks let's talk meat baby let's talk
meat what's my favorite cut of meat my
favorite cut of meat is a steak
all right we've got an episode of taste
buds coming up soon chicken versus steak
you're gonna see my love for the steak
in that episode but i love all kinds of
meats who am i kidding i love a pork
chop i love a chicken wing i love a
chicken leg i love a sausage i love a
bacon i love a ground meat i love
butcher box
because butcher box is bringing me all
these meats
and they're bringing me quality versions
of all these meats and they're bringing
me quality versions all these meats at a
great price what more do you want for
god's sakes
sign up for butcher box
i'm making meals with these people with
what they're sending me i'm frying up
steaks i'm i'm i'm oven baking chickens
i'm i'm doing a sunday gravy tomato
gravy with pork ribs and pork chops i'm
making bacon in the morning i'm making
tacos with the ground beef people this
is how i roll and butcher boxes help me
roll that way all right that's what i'm
talking about what's my favorite thing
about butcher box i can't pick one it's
convenience it's cost its quality i i'm
in love with the whole project i got to
be honest with you all right i want you
guys to get motivated i want you guys to
sign up for butcher box because they are
shipping curated selections of high
quality meat right to your home
right to your home free shipping also in
the continental united states and the
meats have no antibiotics no added
hormones uh you're getting 8 to 14
pounds of meat every month depending on
which box you choose look that's enough
for 24 individual meals people it's
packed ship it's packed fresh and it's
shipped frozen for convenience you could
toss it right in the freezer you don't
have to worry about it going bad all
right this is your chance
to to to not only set up for butcher box
but to also never have to buy ground
beef again they're offering ground beef
for life these people are nuts
sign up at butcherbox.com taste buds
you're gonna get two pounds of ground
beef in every order for free
for the life of your membership you
heard me right for the life of your
membership you're getting two pounds of
ground beef for free with every order
when you go and log on to butcherbox.com
taste buds to claim this deal
well that's an interesting point you
bring up
because when a drink is almost
exclusively ever only put on the
bottomless menu
it means they are banking on the fact
that you will not drink more than two
three i believe the reason it's
bottomless it's because it's served in a
four ounce you know what you'll never
see so it's a couple of swings
you know what you'll never see you'll
never see bottomless jack and cokes
bottomless beans you'll never see a
bottomless bloody mary because you can't
drink more than one nobody's gonna buy
that nobody's to be like but you tell
somebody a bottomless bloody mary even
if they're a bloody mary fan they're
like i'm not going to have more than one
or two bloody marys listen you put
bottomless on a thing you can't sell
you put bottomless on a thing that you
know you're not going to lose your bank
on that's what you put bottomless on you
don't put bottomless on a good seller no
not at all yeah no yes that's true
you're still trying to make money off of
it um that's that's just it's just
appealing let's say that you're gonna
drink long you're gonna order all this
stuff order more food and you up charge
on a bottomless thing and you go i'm not
going to never drink to you the business
model of selling alcohol i worked in a
bar for a cool decade you just started
one but i'm saying
you're such i understand i understand
uh uh margins
in march do you understand margin
well then stay inside yours this is not
a good margin this is not a good margin
by the way you got to order 10
ingredients to put it in right you would
never put a best-selling drink on a
bottomless
special you wouldn't do that i've seen
uh all you can eat sushi that's one of
them a high group where at a 7-eleven
where the [ __ ] have you seen it i went
to one it was one in l.a on the royal
canyon and i got in there and i didn't
realize it was bottomless sushi and the
second i saw the bottom of the sushi i
got a little nervous i was like
oh this is where they eat okay
the fat [ __ ] with ankles spilling over
his socks who's sitting like this
sideways on the table going two
[Laughter]
am
more
wrong i don't know what we're talking
about
[Laughter]
so um the bloody mary uh is apparently
associated with a number of historical
figures uh particularly queen mary of
england who was um attempting to
re-establish the catholic church of
england so
yeah and she burned a bunch of people
that's a hot origin story
but what's your origin story hey
a dumb [ __ ] walked into a
[Laughter]
i actually prefer that over the queen
trying to resurrect
the emotional origin story and if it
doesn't start with the spice girls we're
playing
i'll go buy a bushel a car
[Laughter]
it doesn't say that it's not known at
the origin but it's a celebratory a
drink
i heard celebrities
baby champagne and orange juice i said
it was an i heard it was an alcoholic
stutterer who just was trying to get an
osu
like right now you hello rose can i
answer your question
you ate
you ate three or four different types of
sandwiches yeah you had fried uh
brussels sprouts and fresh fried dough
you had beer before and whiskey before
yes okay and now you're drinking
tomatoes tomato sauce and i feel great
to top it all and i gotta tell you
looking back on my feet this is not
going to mix with all that do you think
your orange juice is i don't mind it i
don't know babe i'm bouncing back right
now i'm ready to do another pop of
whiskey in a second you have no idea
i'm ready to take another slap from this
guy that's disgusting please let's do it
i think it's disgusting i don't know
i've never liked it i think it's uh i
think it's an acquired taste uh item and
i think that that is not okay i think
more people are gonna a sight unseen
drink that like i love it to that and i
think that says something i think that
if something is deemed an acquired taste
it's for a reason but that's like saying
but that's like saying um you know uh uh
mozzarella sticks are better than
oysters because oysters are an acquired
taste that's something come on that has
something to do with it oysters are
better than mozzarella sticks i agree
but that's but you but you get my point
that's got nothing to do with it it
doesn't matter if it's acquired or not
it's a better product there's more
versatility to it well you've got a
broader reach what do you mean why for
every reason two ingredients versus two
ingredients why why is it more two
ingredients you keep saying that that's
not the base the base you said you don't
even need the accoutrement no
the but the base is not just tomato do
you like chewing into the celery do you
like that i do i actually do i do you
burn calories eating celery i know
because it's not it's the uh yeah yeah
yeah okay but you're saying the base you
you think you're burning calories what
about the bacon you're shoving in with
the celery what about the blue cheese
stuffed olive that you're eating in the
interim it's uh it's a wash
[Laughter]
you're saying the base is two
ingredients it's not two ingredients the
basement
alcohol the meat don't think eating
bacon but you're scared of hillary are
you guarding my point you're screwing my
point my point is is the base mixed with
vodka for a bloody mary is not one
ingredient it's it's several things
good try to speak through the
regurgitation of the sauce you just pile
drive down your [ __ ] gullet you just
you just literally you might as well
take the [ __ ] pot off the stove and
just tip it back
and then just do a shot and then drink
the sauce do a shot and then drink the
sauce i know it's got herbs go scratch
with your herbs just scratch
go scratch with the herbs
i love that you whittle it down to
tomato sauce and vodka whereas growing
up in flora much so you're drinking a
tree
and was in the backyard you just threw
this up in the backyard and you [ __ ]
yeah i mean come on man [ __ ] oranges i
won't pass the people a bunch of people
exactly i like what he just said
[ __ ] oranges nobody says i buy fruit
every week everyone says i buy fruity in
the morning every week
i never buy oranges dude i'm kind of
sick of the orange top 10 fruits orange
does not break the [ __ ] list
yes
i agree you crossed the line
watermelon cantaloupe uh cantaloupe
come on i'm trying to stay with you ever
invented you're putting the cake
to yourself listen i love it keep
[ __ ] hold up keep talking keep
talking i got
grapes grapes apples
uh blueberries
strawberries plums cherries yeah
bananas
grapples mango
pineapple
[Laughter]
you are insane if you don't think an
orange is at the top of that list
in front of an orange easy any day
tangerine in front of an orange any
[ __ ] tangerine is the orange's
[ __ ] step daughter no no no no no no
no no it's all tangerine citrus does
what orange does but better yeah by the
way you know one of the most famous you
know one of the most the umbrella of the
orange you know one of the most famous
sinatra songs you're putting this in the
pasta sauce category it is one of the
most famous times for songs is tangerine
tangie you know what he didn't say
orange
but he also didn't sing tomato sauce
there is a sinatra there is a snatcher
here he goes tomato juice there is a
sinatra lyric
he got me i can't think of it sinatra
said the word tomato
the orange is an arrogant fruit no
everybody it thinks it's oh it's got
vitamin c it thinks it's the only
vitamin c the orange is the fruit of
life it's oh stop it
[Music]
your fruit juice is such horseshit
that that entire oranges companies have
to make a campaign out of being like our
orange juice doesn't have a lot of
[ __ ] garbage in it look orange used
to squeeze from this orange juice only
has this much sugar our orange juice
only is this i don't understand the
argument what do you mean you don't
understand it what do you mean 9 out of
10 orange juices are are
a commercial for tomato juice where the
guy goes where sam elliott and the voice
are asked to go our tomato juice doesn't
have a lot of sugar in it
a [ __ ] commercial for tomato juice v8
i should have had a v8 oh
well i don't want to get into the attack
of the [ __ ] killed tomatoes because
they killed away more okay look at me if
i pissed you i got a great point there's
a table of people that have a bunch of
emotions at the table i walk by go oh
bunch of people having a good time over
there you know i walk past a table that
has eight people at it at a restaurant
and everyone has a bloody mary i'm like
these people are burying things down
deep inside they're emote they're
burying their emotions inside you don't
drink a bloody mary unless you've seen
some [ __ ] you've been through some [ __ ]
and you're trying to come out of some
[ __ ] i'll tell you what's happening
at a mimosa table in the morning
selfies
selfies
selfies
that is so [ __ ] accurate you know
what happened you know what's happening
at the table bloody mary's
business deals countries are being
divided
over these bloody people clothing
self-loathing is what's happening oh
these bloody mary's things are happening
things are happening money is driving
around anxiety please yeah please
some [ __ ] zoloft that's what you need
in that i'll tell you what you know what
orange juice you know what a mimosas
it's a slap
it's a will smith slap
you know what a bloody mary is it's a
tyson [ __ ] punch okay
it hits hard this is just because it
hits all your voice and you lean forward
and name two things that have nothing to
do with each other and attach them to
your drink doesn't make it a good
argument well it does i think it does
you know what orange juice is orange
juice is steven spielberg you know what
this is this is [ __ ] steven sergoff
you can't even think of anything
you can't even think of anything you
blank [ __ ] you can't even process
anything go through the process
this is [ __ ] you know what this is this
is the godfather and this is jiggly
no yeah mine was better no it wasn't i'm
saying this is stupid you wanted to get
all freaking you wanted to get started
you tried to you tried to make it
just to save you time in the future you
never have to say the words this is
stupid after something you said i know
already it was stupid okay you know you
can't you can't
you can't you're not you're not you're
smoking mirrors man you're using all the
tricks this is a selfie this is this is
[ __ ] pranks
i agreed i agreed
bert is being quiet like a step child in
the middle of a of of parents fighting
you guys are so good at this but bert am
i wrong what's happening at an emotional
table anything important uh people are
telling each other they got pregnant and
they're like going like i love you and
this is what my father said to me right
before he died and at that table they're
like they're like they're going like do
i look cuteness my lips i should i want
to get filler should i get filler i'm
going to wait i thought your first thing
was the most
he said
this is where you two are right now this
is what you two are
[Music]
[Music]
and i shake that [ __ ] up and i pop the
bottle and it sprays everywhere it's
it's come on and then your buddy's like
my gun's sticky
i drank so much less than you i'm giving
coherent arguments you are falling out
of your chair
and you're pretending to be do you think
i gave him a concussion i i think he
slapped the sense out of you is what i
think
this is only my second beer and i
haven't even shipped it yet i just had
one beer well it's like five
whiskey no i think you had two full
beers
you'll be arrested huh if i pulled you
over right now as a cop and you're so
would you yeah but you know i'm saying
you appear i wouldn't even need to test
you don't don't even you have to walk in
a straight line do the alphabet i bet i
could i bet i could do the finger test
right now
these are two two bloody mary guys
having to do the friggin sobriety test
yeah
nope
well no you gotta hit the tip of your
nose you try and let's be honest you
aren't missing that nose
what does that mean
no you missed it too i hit it right here
no no no
yeah you went in you went in and touched
the sides of your nose to the tip
no you missed it again
that's at the tip
you're hitting the sides
what do you mean what do you mean wait
will you do it
watch watch it at the tip of your nose
see what v yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know what i can't do even when i'm
stone sober say the alphabet backwards i
think that's unfair that one it's cause
like i said earlier c
c q y r s t w i i i would be [ __ ] if
that was my driver you guys play wordle
i started three days ago me too i swear
to god three days did you do today i
didn't do today's yet
[Laughter]
yeah that was hard and then last uh this
morning we did last night don't say it
to me yeah i mean i've been really doing
so what is the game i i keep hearing it
gives you it gives you
like five six letters and you've got to
try to guess the word based on the on
the letter on the words well you need to
spell and have a vocabulary
word
it's bigger than it's more than two
three like words i understand thank you
yeah what is the game how do you play it
it's on it's called i'm asking you to
play it
you got
you got six chances to guess the five
letter word from scratch if you write a
word that you think it is in it'll tell
you if uh a letter's in the right place
a letter is correct but in the wrong
place or the letter is not in there
and then you by process of elimination
within 60 sizes you have to get it's
like right here right so then you got to
guess a word and so does it give you a
hint nope you got to start i always
start with audio because it's got a lot
of vowels in it and then you submit the
word and it says okay that u is where it
should be that o is in the word but it's
not where it should be okay you gotta
try to figure out the word there and you
get six tries
wow it's pretty it's actually pretty fun
it is fun yeah i would guess luigi
ouija nym
oh i didn't play yet why would those
letters are in the right place all right
let's do it how do you spell it
[Music]
what no no no no that's right let's try
it
you're pretty close so o and u are the
first two letters and now the last three
we don't know yet so what words start
with oh you
[Laughter]
you can just go to
google and start typing
where's the point no hold on a second
actually the word absolutely hold on a
second let's let mr [ __ ] uh mensa
genius over here do it since he said
that he was so much smarter than me go
ahead you got two letters three times
i've gotten it every time guys
i got the first try which i heard is not
coming
i put in on
not the first one but then i put the
next word okay so
depot
oh wow what a big word oh you
why do you have to focus you're so good
at it you said hey can someone give me
one more beer please
no wait you can have my hold on here
take my beer no no we don't need
[Music]
house
no it's gotta you only have three more
letters okay up up up
[Music]
no it's great this is a great podcast
this i know this is just an app it's not
not the daily one no
i like to practice no i just thought
you'd put your money where your mouth
was
yeah but this is how the game's played
yet
it's a puzzle you sit here and you have
to do it yeah you put in your pocket
it's weird i got the first two letters
right off the bat but yeah no good you
did you know what you did you did
actually
almost nailed it right away but
because you're wrong
i don't know how do you i think that's
looks right to me
no that no they would tell you if those
letters were in it
yeah
okay i shouldn't be doing this right now
okay all right we'll pause it okay
but for nothing a slider came out and i
think should make a good drink
i think we flip up a chicken throw it in
there you ever seen the ones have the
chicken in them no what's that no no i
mean now it's now that's good you've
seen
it's so [ __ ] sexy
they give you a bloody mary and it's
your fault i don't want to throw my
chicken into a glass but wait what's
interesting a chicken
type in chicken bloody mary like a full
chicken a full [ __ ] chicken look at
this
that looks terrible that looks that
looks hysterical it looks ridiculous
come on this is what you got to do with
this drink you need you need to roll
people in you have to dangle a full bird
in front of it in order for people to
want to drink that that's the limit is
the point
a couple of squash fresh squeezed
oranges a little top it over a little
bubbly and that's it google skip it
around google google um uh uh greatest
mimosa of all time
i just want to see what comes up
i want to see what comes up you got some
good champagne you guys might
see a mimosa with a cherry in it at best
at best you're not getting anything the
point is is you're grounded here there's
nothing to do
this is a blonde look at that look at
that oh you know what i didn't even get
various look at that it's appealing it's
vibrant it's colorful if you say if you
type in naked blonde they all look the
same if you type in naked redhead you
get a lot of different pictures
the the parallels that you guys have
two people understanding each other no i
haven't even touched it i'm not a fan of
them
did you not drink any of it i'm kidding
no i'm trying to [ __ ] or did you get
a second one no no no no no notice by
the way when we started this podcast how
where are we at
58 he drank every single thing but the
bloody mary everything that is as as
much as i attract my whole bloody mary
of course you did because you are the
guy that's what you you i'll attach
bloody mary to you that's fine for my
argument what do you mean just the fact
that you like bloody mary's gives the
bloody
i checked my whole bloody mary i enjoyed
it quite a bit i understand and that's
why bloody mary is going to get a thumbs
down you're the type of guy that drinks
it all right let's
all right let's see what do you do we go
to the polls
we need to you're supposed by the way
it's supposed to be a rose battle in 10
minutes you're supposed to be a
legitimate legion of escapes i mean it's
7 50 p.m you're supposed to be a
legitimate gangster in 10 minutes
luckily i don't think lewis is a
stickler for
proximity i'm [ __ ] wasted proximity
yeah you mean punctuality that's it oh
boy
oh boy we're in a state over here oh you
got you're going to the polls all right
drum roll
and we're going to the polls here
167 votes and i'm gonna
click on bloody mary
[Music]
just turn it around
don't say it let's just turn it we got
what do we got i can't see oh
my god
79.1
that is idiot 20.9
it's 80 20. that's one of the biggest
margins we've a victory we've ever had
might be the biggest i don't think we've
ever crossed over to the teams that
might be like second third biggest
that's idiot
66 say mimosa oh my so i'm coming away
with two wins and
he's had support
just just make your bloody bed
and get in it i just pour the second one
i can't believe can i read can i can i
can you just read some some of the let's
go to the phones
i want to hear what what the people have
to say i can't believe it was that i
can't believe that i'm shocked
i'm shocked at that do you want to read
something are you going to go to read
something yeah i'll read i'll read you
from both sides
okay
i don't even know the difference but i
pick all right that's not good
my father would drink bloody marys and
then beat me when i was a child
okay i don't like tomato soup or juice
but add a little vodka to the juice and
a cheese sausage pickle olive and i'm in
that's just to me that goes to my to my
argument
mimosas are a bs drink for people who
think they're fancy no buzz not worth
the calories bloody mary cures the
hangover gave you the night before it's
a meal with a slider bacon chicken wing
etc this is again this is the look at
this okay look at this [ __ ] bloody
mary
oh my god no
are those deep-fried raviolis
that looks [ __ ] awesome what is that
come on guys that's your wife at 52
getting dressed up to go out hold on a
second hold on a second hold on a second
let me just say this and i and i lost
and i accept it but let me just say this
that's like pulling up the pictures of
uh cheeseburgers where the bun is
grilled cheese sandwiches and going look
at this look what you have to do to the
cheeseburger to make it good that's not
what that is bloody mary's are our food
items you're gonna start stuffing one
more metaphor that doesn't make sense
right before the buzzer huh no that's
that's a thing okay it's like it's like
look at the crazy cheeseburger this
place made yeah heart attack cafe huge
thing born so my point is is just like
the cheeseburger bloody mary's are a
thing a food item where you try to make
it even crazier than the last guy made
it it doesn't mean it needs it it's for
spectacle i
four to one people prefer a mimosa why
are you continuing that four to one
people are stupid i'm sure they are they
are sure they are if i'm gonna start my
day off drinking it's not gonna be a
spicy ketchup and a cup at least mimosa
has oj in it mimosa i black out at
breakfast with no health benefits bloody
mary i black out and drool peacefully
knowing my metabolism is boosted
andy milinakis says soft ass [ __ ]
chosen mosta get the [ __ ] out of here
you lukewarm iq weirdos
thank you andy milan knocking yeah
before i drink one of those tomato
monstrosities oh my god i once went to
brunch with someone who recommended a
bloody mary picture i'll never trust
them again
that's ridiculous that's so i'm not big
on champagne but it's a million times
better than the garbage disposal of
ingredients that goes into a bloody mary
well we're not talking champagne that's
the problem we're talking champagne mix
with orange juice that's [ __ ] go
ahead okay i once heard a man in the
airport at 9am maybe bert say he drinks
85 percent of his bloody mary's at the
airport i might that might have been
this day i don't know what it means it
haunts me uh
[Music]
again my point a businessman yup making
deals holes messed with my acid reflux
but mimosas i choose because i was
forced to drink v8 juice as a child and
i hated my aunt that doesn't count
mimosas are a crowd favorite that all
can enjoy even if you like orange juice
more than champagne or vice versa you
can just pour more of one ingredient in
the drink not everyone likes the taste
of tomatoes does it count
mimosa has class a bloody mary i feel
like i'm drinking period juice looks
foul and is fat okay it doesn't count
somebody trying to be funny not a real
point keep going yeah
bring me somebody that's got a real
point and isn't trying to just make a
joke and be funny
because that's the thing i'm just
reading who thought it was a good idea
to make a cocktail with a juice no one
wants and a vegetable that gets thrown
out on every plate of finished buffalo
wings
that true sorry
not true at all mimosas are fine but uh
okay if you haven't chosen bloody mary
go find your nearest bin and get in it
stay there and wait you will eventually
arrive where you belong at an energy
recovery plant or a landfill i don't
know what that's that was a long way to
go everybody's trying to be funny these
aren't real these aren't real points
about either drink either drink even
though we even though more of them are
negative about uh the bloody mary i will
say there is very little here to support
the mimosa also
i've never enjoyed people's rebranding
of a spicy pizza sauce into an alcoholic
beverage nasty anyone who saw the bloody
mary over momosa needs a daily wellness
check going forward
i'm just reading you maybe choosing the
most is here only because the bloody
mary is inferior to the caesar i don't
know what that means this is different
it's a different drink okay and by the
way yeah we should have talked about
clamato that's what the class that's
terrible that you don't like that i do
oh bro i hate that
i hope joe doesn't choose bloody mary or
it's going to be a washout victory which
it was blackjack snack
all right
all right how far is this how far is the
stand from here five minutes two minutes
yeah
uh there it is in a car i'm happy to
take that eighty percent okay well he
call an uber
lubbers away
all right i lost one what can i do you
know i lost it's that hurts i lost the
last one too i'm back down again i was i
was like kind of gaining on you for a
second but i'm back out thank you to
burke crusher thank you guys
uh birdie boy relapse tour i'm on the
road i'm on the road i'm in your city
colorado i know that i just made a big
announcement uh i made a big
announcement uh that sal is involved
with so go check out that announcement
at burberrybird.com yes beautiful don't
say what it is yeah not yet okay wait i
don't know when's this error
two to four weeks
okay
uh we'll well don't actually well well
the the last one we did will go up next
week right
and then right to four weeks depending
if we want to slot it in a row all right
it takes announces wednesday april 6th
take it easy right
okay so this will be after this
uh
yeah it will be okay yeah yeah hey guys
get your tickets for the fully loaded
comedy festival it is me sal
david tell uh felipe i shouldn't name
all the names because i don't know who's
accepted yet nikki glazer taylor
tomlinson uh mark norman big j
it's a it's it's it's we're adding
comics to the whole lineup we are
performing at minor league baseball
stadiums arenas um amphitheaters and one
raceway get your tickets we're all gonna
be doing shows we're gonna have an
intermission should be 10 comics a show
it's going to be [ __ ] outrageous go
to burperbert.com fully loaded comedy
tour this is my first official announce
for that i haven't really dialed it in
yet baby i love it yeah thank you very
much yeah so we'll see you guys on the
road
well i i won't i wasn't invited to be a
part of this well we haven't finished
the lineup this year especially they're
still adding comics but evidence we're
adding comics joe one of their best
friends and business partner
the uh
unfucking real
unreal it's just unreal do you want to
plug anything besides misery
what else is there
all right fine no i already plugged i
plugged i mean i mean
in may i mean i meant houston oh boy but
they come and take it fest in houston
and i go right over to the creek and
cave from there to do four shows uh in
austin texas it's gonna be a lot of fun
uh in july i will be at the punch line
in san francisco and then i will also be
going
well
let me hold on that
come to joey roses
joda wrote what i'm i'm just saying i
mean i hear the people clicking the
channel you know
you gotta you gotta get in there you got
a little zest
you gotta get in there little gusto i'm
doing with you you're tapering off
you're going into a drunken stupor in
the middle of your plucks let's get with
us what are you talking about i mean
you're getting you're putting everybody
to sleep
i want you to sell tickets babe put pull
yourself out of this [ __ ] tomato
juice hole i think i'm going to start
using the term babe i love it i love it
so much hearing you guys toss it back
and forth i want to be a part of it i
want
come on hey but me and chris i want you
all to no actually don't go on hey babe
let taste buds have its own thing for
five [ __ ] seconds how about that
oh the mighty hey babe we all have to
[ __ ] move aside so him and [ __ ]
the stefano can do their tour
i gotta [ __ ] wait for him to tell me
when he's available oh me and chrissy
are on tour yeah if i was ten feet from
a guy that had coveted he doesn't want
to [ __ ] come in my presence
we'll be adding joe derosa to the fully
loaded tour oh yeah guys you want to see
that get down there and get those
tickets to see that
make sure you check out hey babe
everybody it's such a good show
comedy.com on tour louisville evansville
oklahoma san diego may 21st la may 22nd
and here in new york city at the beacon
on may 14th the greek cinco de mayo
birdie boy relapse tour
jonah
come and take it festival in houston and
may straight into austin at the creek
and cave and i'll be at the punch line
in san francisco
in july
oh and coming to joey roses
joeyrosesnyc.com for details we're open
tuesday through
sunday uh thank you thank you guys for
coming thank you taking time out of your
day i know you're on tour with us we
appreciate you being here you're a great
guest that was fun fun two episodes uh
and that's been hey babe uh
that's been tastebuds i'm going to your
memories thanks for your memories
you're just an [ __ ] i'm going to
taste buds uh this that has been taste
buds and i still love you babe
[ __ ] off man
[Laughter]
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds taste
buddy